let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 listen for your area code we'll start
with our caller from the 603 area code
who's been holding on for a while a
caller from 603 go ahead hey how are you
do good who's this Jake yeah go ahead
so I have a few kind of questions to
kind of span the spectrum so the first
is do you believe gender is a social
construct do gender so obviously I don't
believe that sex is a social construct I
believe that there are elements of
gender that become sort of normalized by
cultural norms for sure but you know I
feel like just answering the question in
the most general sense usually doesn't
really clear anything up usually when
people ask that they have sort of like a
more specific question they're driving
at sure sure yeah I mean the kind of the
way I acted in such a vague way was kind
of for that reason specifically it seems
to be in certain circles in the left
there is no debate so I was curious what
you thought about it I guess my next
question would be have you ever heard of
John McWhorter no I have not okay I
would I would suggest looking him up
he's an intellectual
he's consistently on a on a podcast with
a guy named Glenn Lowry and they have
quite a lot to stay on the issues I
think that you would be quite interested
in alright I have no idea what their
views are I might find their views
deplorable or interesting I couldn't
comment I think that you would actually
find their views quite understandable
and that's kind of why I'm suggesting
them to you
John McWhorter but his last name is
spelled MC WH o r ter McGaha I highly
recommend you look him up he's a very
smart person he's taught it I think
Harvard and Brown Glenn Lowry is a
professor at Brown so they're not
deplorable by any stretch of the
imagination my next question is have you
ever heard of the global terrorism index
and do you think it's reliable or a good
resource I I have heard of it I don't I
couldn't tell you offhand what
organizations are involved
so I would not be able to speak to its
reliability offhand well it is the
product of the University of Maryland I
don't know if you've ever so it's kind
of an academic rooted group but they
actually they have statistics and I've
never actually heard them debated but
you know I'm curious to see someone like
you're yourself what you would think
about it alright Jake I will check it
out I think three questions is probably
good for today thank you so much I do
appreciate the call